ils ont les mêmes droits fondamentaux
que vous et moi et que les citoyens sauf
deux le droit de vote et d'être élues et
le droit d'entrée de rester dans le pays
tous les autres droits appartiennent à
tout le monde en français chacun en
anglais everyone tout le monde a droit à
la santé droit à l'éducation droit de ne
pas être torturé droit à un procès juste
et équitable droit à l'égalité dans la
mentalité de beaucoup de gens de manière
intuitive
beaucoup de gens pensent que les
migrants n'ont pas les mêmes droits
beaucoup de gens s'imaginent que les
migrants s'ils veulent des droits ils
peuvent aller chez eux les migrants se
trouvent dans une situation très
précaire
il n'y a pas de ils n'ont pas de voix
politiques
il ya personne qui prend leur parti qui
prend leur défense et eux mêmes ne se
mobilise pas et ne proteste pas pour la
simple raison que quand ils se
mobilisent qu'ils protestent ils
s'identifient et s'ils sont identifiés
ça veut dire qu'on peut les arrêter les
détenir les déportés et ça c'est la
première peur du migrant surtout de
migrants clandestins
j'ai vu des conditions de détention
absolument épouvantable dans divers pays
détention dans des endroits qui ne sont
absolument pas adapté à la détention
des conteneurs des commissaires des sous
sols de commissariat de police avec une
surpopulation extraordinaires des deux
vrais porcherie des trucs qui était
complètement à la campagne qui avait dû
être des bâtiments industriels
j'ai vu des hangars à laquelle on
détenait les gens sans aucun meuble
en ce moment à montréal
les enfants à l'école on demande les
papiers d'immigration ou les certificats
de citoyenneté des parents ce qui est
d'abord une distinction en fait une
distinction entre tel enfant et l enfant
il faudrait pouvoir le justifier or
l'enfant a droit à l'éducation
c'est dans tous les textes
internationaux que le canada a ratifié
et le canal enfants n'est pas
responsable de la situation
administrative de ses parents pourquoi
est-ce qu'on lui interdit d'aller à
l'école et on sait que par exemple à
toronto
tous les enfants vont à l'école on ne
pose pas la question du statut
migratoire des parents c'est interdit
aux écoles de poser la question du
statut migratoire des parents ils
prennent tous les enfants selon la
résidence dans le district
coût des mesures anti mines
dans le monde entier c'est hallucinant
de voir combien on dépense sans qu'il y
ait de protestation et en six ans mais
on pourrait faire tout cet argent là
pourraient servir à booster l'économie a
créé des emplois à des rats combien
d'américains ont protesté à propos du
coût du mur qui a été construit entre
les etats-unis et le mexique qui a coûté
mais des centaines de millions de
dollars et qui est parfaitement inutile
mais qui est une oeuvre symbolique c'est
parfaitement symbolique c'est totalement
inutile les flux migratoires se sont
déplacées ailleurs c'est tout ce que ça
a fait
aucun pays nav
développer des alternatives à la
détention or les alternatives à la
détention c'est quelque chose que l'on
voit maintenant en droit pénal
plutôt que de détenir on va donner des
travaux communautaires
plutôt que de détenir on va assigner à
résidence plutôt que de détenir on va
demander de déposer une caution d'avoir
quelqu'un qui vous garantissent que vous
allez vous représentez